it's seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast here are our top stories this
morning masks on for lessons secondary
school pupils in england told to wear
face coverings in the classroom
prepare for another ping demick the
government warns that up to a quarter of
all workers could be absent due to
coving
three people are thought to have died
after wildfires destroyed hundreds of
homes in the u.s state of colorado
the forest fallout farmers in wales
claimed plans to develop new woodland
could decimate rural communities
to see it destroyed
just for an investment company to be
able to plant trees to me is is
and vets in ireland appeal for a
national dog blood bank to help save the
lives of seriously ill pets
the weather will keep the warm
southwesterly conditions today but it
will turn colder as the winds become
more northerly
and at quarter two we'll take a look at
the papers with consultants and all the
allison stewart allen and the sunday
mirrors political editor nigel nelson
[Music]
a very good morning thanks to your
company today i'm jonathan samuels the
government is introducing further
covered restrictions in some schools in
england as it warns kovid could cause
mass absences at work as the number of
new cases in england reaches a record
high all secondary school pupils will
have to wear face coverings in class
meanwhile ministers are drawing up
contingency plans for large-scale
workplace absences after government
forecasts said up to 25 of staff could
be off in the new year so secondary
school students in england will once
again be asked to wear masks in
classrooms and move the government says
we'll maximize the number of children in
school for the maximum amount of time
the recommendation which affects both
schools and colleges is temporary
remaining in place until the 26th of
january when regulations will be
reviewed an additional 7 000 air
cleaning units will also be provided to
schools in order to improve ventilation
in teaching spaces well let's get more
now on those plans to cope with rising
absences at work caused by the spread of
omicron malayana vesselnovich is at the
department of health for us this morning
it's a real problem isn't it this uh not
only uh in the nhs but in lots of other
areas of life as well
that's right and ministers are really
worried that this wave of omicron may
really disrupt essential public services
so the prime minister has tasked
different departmental ministers to
stress test their sectors to see how
they would cope with up to a quarter of
staff being ill and steve barclay the
chancellor of the duchy of lancaster is
in charge of meeting with the ministers
and seeing how that capacity will cope
and we already know that train services
are disrupted across the country
including close by in victoria station
that serves not just cities on the south
coast but also commuter areas of london
which certainly it will be a problem for
key workers trying to get into work of
course the nhs we've had in the last
month the number of staff absences
because of covid has doubled and that
coupled with the rising hospital
admissions can
push the health service beyond full
stretch as we've had from different nhs
leaders and of course
the government really doesn't want to go
back to teaching pupils at home we know
what a detrimental effect that can have
on particularly the youngest pupils for
so for that reason now that a new
recommendation and rule for secondary
school pupils to wear masks in
classrooms they already are recommended
to wear them in communal areas now
health secretary sergeant javed has said
that
he will only introduce further
restrictions in the most extreme of
circumstances but various
public sector bodies and leaders are
warning that with the numbers she number
omicron infections even if
they are milder that still means people
have to self-isolate and still means
that in the coming weeks we might face
significant disruption to some essential
public services
okay malena thank you
well we can show you the latest official
coveted data now 162
572 new cases were reported in england
that's the highest figure for england
since the pandemic began it is likely to
be the same picture in the rest of the
uk but the figures haven't yet been
published because of the holiday now
official figures show the kovid 19
vaccine program is now the biggest in uk
history around 132 million jabs were
given across 2021 more than 47 million
second doses have been administered
that's 84.2 percent of people in the uk
over the age of 12. one and a half
million people received their booster
dose in the final week of 2021 which
brings the number of boosted adults in
the uk to 34 million
also making news this morning a group of
conservative mps and peers has called on
the prime ministers to scrap taxes on
domestic energy bills writing in the
sunday telegraph the group says the
government is causing gas and
electricity costs to increase faster
than other countries because of taxes
also green levees that are on bills
let's take you to south africa these are
live pictures of that fire that's broken
out at the country's main parliament
building a huge amount of smoke there
going into the sky the blaze broke out
at the building which is in cape town a
few hours ago
flames have been seen coming through the
roof of the national assembly as you can
see plenty of fire trucks on the scene
there as they try and bring things under
control that we'll keep across that for
you
police in colorado say three people are
missing after wildfires swept across
large parts of the u.s state it's now
thought nearly a thousand homes were
destroyed by the fires while tens of
thousands of people have been forced to
leave the area skies emma birchley
reports
destruction as far as the eye can see
homes cars still smoldering
the first of the fires was reported late
on thursday morning possibly started by
a fallen power line but it rapidly
spread
fueled by winds of more than a hundred
miles per hour
powerful gusts or flames leapfrog some
homes then flatten others
it was pretty shocking
we didn't think that the fire was going
to come back in this part of the
neighborhood
we were trying to stay hopeful and then
all that came crashing down when we saw
our house up in flames so
it was hard but we're just glad that
we're all safe
swathes of land the size of football
pitches were swallowed up in a matter of
seconds whole neighborhoods reduced to
ash
historic droughts and heat waves have
created the perfect fuel for the flames
the snow may have arrived now but it
wasn't in time it was kind of eerie and
we saw ash and all kinds of stuff
falling from the sky
thankfully the what's falling from the
sky is white now and that's really
helping obviously to
kind of kill kill the fires hopefully
that'll kind of
really knock it down
the cities of louisville and superior
home to 34 000 people had to be
evacuated it makes you want to choke up
and cry it's like
christmas just passed and then
you know everything that they went
through is just gone
they spent one more christmas morning in
their house one a week ago and now
they're not able to spend new year's
it's
very unfortunate
even when the fire didn't wreak its
hellish havoc the force of the wind did
the job instead
the governor of colorado described the
fire as a force of nature and declared a
state of emergency it means disaster
funds can be accessed
but in streets like these there's not a
single thing to salvage
and for those who lived here it'll mean
starting again
emma birchley sky news
let's take a look at some of the other
stories this morning a judge in the
united states has rejected an appeal by
prince andrews lawyers to throw out a
lawsuit brought against him by a woman
who says he sexually assaulted her when
she was 17. virginia dufrese says she
was abused by the prince on multiple
occasions in 2001 while she was being
sexually assaulted by financial geoffrey
epstein prince andrew has denied all the
allegations made against him
the speaker of the house of commons has
called for all former prime ministers to
be knighted sir lindsey hoyle said the
honour should be given for what he
called one of the toughest jobs in the
world after tony blair was made a sir in
the new year's honors list
let's return then to one of our top
stories this morning that announcement
that all secondary school pupils in
england are going to have to wear face
coverings in class at the start of the
new term in a few days and i'm joined
now by jeff barton general secretary of
the association of school and college
leaders good to see you this morning
thanks for joining us so early on on a
sunday so musk's back in the classroom
good
idea well i don't think anybody is going
to throw up their hands and rejoice at
the idea jonathan but on the other hand
lots of parents were saying lots of
teachers were saying well if my child
was going to school in wales in northern
ireland in scotland they have been
expected to wear facial rings in the
classroom for a long time and i think
there is one sense that what we had last
week from the prime minister last sunday
in fact was schools are going to stay
open at all costs no disruption
but nothing to back that up at least
what we've now got
is a sense that there will be some
mitigation some measures short term one
of which is masks
in order to try and make sure that exams
can take place and that young people can
be where they need to be from tuesday
almost in the
classroom um some will say of course
that they're not very helpful to
learning they're not uh uh uh much fun
to wear obviously in the classroom but
also they're actually going to make
things difficult for teaching staff as
well and if we're not being told to wear
them in restaurants in pubs uh in plenty
of other places even in in the workplace
then why should we have to wear them in
schools no i think i think it's a really
legitimate kind of question i'm not here
to say face coverings are a good thing
or a bad thing i'm an educationist but
what i would say
is that we know that this
virus is hugely transmissible and very
transmissible by young people we know
that it's airborne transmission and
therefore if what face coverings does is
to allow young people as they are in
other parts of the uk to play their part
in stopping some of that transmission in
order to keep both their peers of the
students but also their teachers in the
classroom and that's being done for a
fixed time it seems to me that that is a
reasonable cost now there will be some
of my colleagues in other unions who
have been calling for face coverage they
think it is absolutely appropriate
that's really not my territory my
territory is we want young people not to
have remote learning to be in the
classroom and if part of the way you do
that is through face coverings then we
would support that
okay you've also been calling for for
help to make classrooms better
ventilated um you'll be pleased
that the education secretary has
announced further 7 000 air cleaning
units to be provided building on the
1000 already announced and we also know
more than 300 000 of those at co2
monitors as well i mean that's all
big steps in the right direction i think
so i mean there will be people watching
who are running our schools and colleges
knowing they've got to open their school
on tuesday let's say thinking well hold
on a minute why is it on a sunday
morning i'm finding out a bit more about
things that could have been done
previously but hey in the spirit of of
the new year let's welcome the fact that
there's now a recognition that those co2
monitors don't sort out your ventilation
they simply help you to know whether
there is an issue with ventilation and i
think the track record with them is what
they're generally showing is that lots
of classrooms don't need anything
further because the ventilation is fine
but what the secretary of state is now
saying is there is going to be a kind of
backup of 7 000 um air purifiers now the
only thing around that of course is
we've got far more than 7 000 schools
and indeed far more than 7 000
classrooms so there's a bit of a
question about the detail the logistics
how is this going to work we don't want
an arms race between some schools
getting them some schools not so there's
details to go through but i go back to
my earlier point if we know that
ventilation is one key ingredient then
both in terms of the face coverings
trying to stop transmission and the air
purifiers those seem to be two helpful
steps which do more than the rhetoric
that we had from the prime minister last
sunday
yeah we're all hoping uh desperately
hoping that schools uh remain open uh as
we go forward um tell me about staff
absences because that's a real problem
isn't it teachers and uh teaching staff
becoming sick with coveted and not being
able to go in
well that's the big unknown i mean we're
seeing from from what you're reporting
the huge pressure on the nhs on retail
we're seeing sporting events being
cancelled uh teaching and all the other
staffing schools are a microcosm of
society and the difficulty for the
people i represent to school and college
leaders is they won't know until tuesday
morning eight o'clock when they start to
get phone calls as to how many staff
have tested positive and therefore will
not be coming in school and it's not
like we've got lines around the block of
supply teachers who can suddenly at the
last minute step in to do that that's
the biggest risk i think to us having
no disruption and what we do is we keep
our fingers crossed and hope that we can
have as many teachers current teachers
and teaching assistants and former
teachers and teaching assistants being
able to be part of the workforce from
next week
yeah because in the dean sahar we did
put out that plea didn't he for retired
teachers people have left the profession
uh people who've perhaps gone part-time
to to to help out uh during this time of
crisis um uh
are people taking up that call
i think it's quite hard to know it's
worth just reminding ourselves that that
kind of noble call to arms uh was made
right at the end of term so basically
into into the holidays and we also know
that because sort of good teachers good
college teachers and school teachers
will have been thinking about this for a
long time and making their own
contingency plans weren't they
they will have done and the way that
works jonathan you know i was ahead for
15 years is if even in normal times if
we remember those if you had some
members of staff who were away you would
call upon people who were on the supply
register had had their safeguarding
checks who would drop everything and say
yes i'll come into school today
there are fewer of those around at the
moment and some of them perhaps will be
more anxious about whether they want to
be stepping into school at the moment or
they might have got other roles they
might be doing tutoring with the
government's tutoring program but
similarly if you're getting people who
weren't part of that uh kind of armies
of support who are now being signed up
for it the question is will they be
ready in time will their safeguarding
checks have come through ready for
tuesday morning i think we just don't
know the figures we know lots of people
have looked at the government website
but in terms of how many people have
actually signed up we're not going to
know i think until next week
um and just before we let you go a
couple of other points very quickly uh
ofsted
a very stressful time isn't it for
schools when they know ofsted are coming
to inspect do you think that needs to be
uh deferred um
and also what about um the issue uh when
it comes to um
what was the other thing i was going to
ask you i was going to well tell me
about ofsted first and i'll try and
remember my other point
sure um so a couple of points about
ofsted i mean i think
uh it's important to say that what
happened on on friday is
all of those unions involved in
education support staff and teaching
staff and leadership unions
simply put out a statement saying there
are a number of things that you need to
do in order to try and make schools as
normal as possible one of those is you
can't have ofsted conducting itself as
if it's business as usual
there are some schools who continue to
welcome ofsted inspections because they
want to get out of special measures but
there aren't many of those it has to be
said so i think there's two things just
to say around austin first of all this
is a recognition by reducing the
workforce that it isn't business as
usual and let's let teachers focus on
the most important thing teaching
children and young people and we'll come
back to inspection at some point in the
future but secondly what viewers might
not have been aware of is the way that
ofsted inspections have taken place in
the past is a lot of their workforce
have been serving school and college
leaders now frankly we want those school
leaders to be in their schools working
with their pupils not heading off to
other schools to do it and that's
essentially what's being called for
there we would strongly welcome that
yeah um interesting point um and i've
done my revision um i was going to ask
you about exams um do you think they
will go ahead as normal this year
i think there's an absolute
determination not just from the
government from the profession itself we
know on february the 7th is going to be
some announcement about changes to exams
so that young people know that there
will be some changes to content they
might get some prior information about
some of their exams etc i think that
pretty much looks like it can go ahead
as normal at the moment but frankly
these are strange times of uncertainty
and who knows what might happen before
february the 7th
all right jeff good to speak to you jeff
barton association of school and college
leaders thank you very much
indeed let's hope 2022 sees a lot less
disruption for our children that schools
are reopening of course uh in the next
few days now farmers in wales say plans
to develop new woodland could decimate
rural communities private investment
firms have bought several large farms
with plans to create brand new forests
and offset carbon emissions sky stan
whitehead reports
deep in komathansha's rolling hills
little has changed in centuries
but land once farmed here by families is
moving into new hands
not to locals but to multi-billion pound
investment firms
those fields you know
that's generations of hard work to see
it destroyed
just for an investment company to be
able to plant trees to me is
is is
this is incredibly upsetting
in the tiny village of courty cadnoe
lies frongok farm
it was recently bought by london-based
investment company foresight group which
has plans to plant thousands of trees
here
but locals fear swathes of conifers
could damage the very landscape
trees are a good thing and we want to
promote
tree growth what we're looking at is the
wrong trees for ecological and
environmental purposes not only does it
affect the visual and the spatial
enjoyment of this beautiful area
but it really has an impact on everybody
who lives here
mass tree planting is not just an issue
at frongok it's understood around a
dozen farms in wales have been snapped
up by companies outside of the country
it is easy to see the attraction for
outside investors firstly simply owning
the land is obviously a significant
asset
secondly they can make money from timber
grown here and thirdly they can sell
carbon credits from the trees they plant
to any company that wants to offset its
carbon footprint
the welsh government wants to plant 86
million trees by the end of this decade
with substantial grants available but it
does admit it is keen to avoid outside
interests buying up welsh land
foresight group told sky news its plans
for new woodlands are an activity which
is recognized by the welsh government as
an important part of the twin fights
against climate change and biodiversity
loss
it added we will be planting a diverse
species mix at frank gok
foresight never plants trees on land
that can support productive commercial
food crop growth
the national farmers union in wales
welcomes tree planting schemes but says
they should complement farming not
replace it if you've seen a monoculture
approach to this and a blanket
deforestation that's a fundamental
change that's not what we're looking for
here in wales a fundamental change in
what way to a community well to it well
it's decimation of that community really
isn't it
this aspect of the valley will be
obliterated community concern comes amid
big climate change targets
changing the landscape could be the
price to pay
in order to meet them dan whited sky
news in court academy comarthinger
we take you back to south africa now
live pictures of that fire that's broken
out of the country's main parliament
building it broke out in the building in
cape town earlier on today flames have
been seen coming through the roof of the
national
assembly it wasn't immediately clear if
anyone was in the building still waiting
for confirmation about that the fire on
the third story
initial reports saying that it started
in
the office space there and then spread
towards the gym certainly there seems to
be a lot more smoke coming from that
roof than there was around about an hour
ago
a
mayoral committee member who's
responsible for safety and security
has said that the roof area caught a
light um in the sort of early hours of
this morning
and we know that a number of fire trucks
are on the scene don't seem to be any bl
any flames at the moment they seem to
have dampened down the flames but still
a huge amount of smoke
i will keep across that story for you
throughout the morning
right now let's take a look at the
weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
we'll keep the warm southwesterly today
but it will turn colder next week as the
winds become more northerly it's mostly
mild but windy now with the scattering
showers over central and western parts
but southern britain and eastern parts
of both scotland and ireland are mostly
fine the morning will stay windy with
blustery showers taking over more of the
west's frequent and prolonged in places
eastern britain will largely dry up
it'll be cooler than yesterday but still
very mild for january now as a dog owner
this is something i've never thought
about before it's rather fascinating one
of ireland's top animal hospitals has
called for the establishment of a uk
style national dog blood bank to help
treat sick pets ucd veterinary hospital
in dublin had to issue an urgent appeal
for donors over christmas because
supplies ran dangerously low our island
correspondent stephen murphy has more
bertie the miniature schnauzer out for
his morning walk he's a lucky dog two
months ago the four-year-old developed a
sudden immune disorder and was rushed to
hospital in dublin during his treatment
he received a life-saving blood
transfusion as an owner you tend not to
think of
blood donors for dogs but without that
blood donation partly would have died so
we went
from be having a perfectly healthy dog
to a dog
that just would not have survived
without that blood donation
he visited the hospital which was
recently forced to issue an urgent
appeal for dog blood donors to come
forward after exhausting its supply
there are no dogs scheduled to give
blood here today so i've brought my own
one along this is bodhi as he fulfills
all the criteria for donating blood he's
more than happy to volunteer he just
doesn't know it yet
as bodhi is prepped to give blood the
vets here stress just how life-saving
these donations can be
pretty much for all the patients that we
would give blood routinely in a hospital
it will not gonna survive if we don't
give them the transfusion
and we would not be able in some cases
more elective cases not be able to get a
diagnosis and know exactly what's wrong
with them and help them if they would
not receive the blood as well
with the help of a little sedative
body's donation is underway all the
blood used here at the hospital is from
local donations like this
kevin murtagh who worked for several
years in england says it's about time
ireland had a centralized national blood
bank like that in the uk
in ireland we don't have that we don't
have that system that luxury and the
blood that we give our patients is
completely dependent on and public
bringing their dog to us and
donating and i suppose i would
absolutely be in support of something
similar in in ireland a similar system
that's that's available in the uk a
proper national bloodline exactly
exactly because it would and it would
make i suppose treating our patients
more efficient so bodhi's donation is
finished he's none the worst for where
he's even got his very own blood donor
card that's one more unit of blood for
the hospital here but they say they'll
always need more donations
for every gift of blood from a body
there's a bertie who gets a second
chance at life
stephen murphy sky news in dublin
i guess you could call them bloodhounds
couldn't you um okay
now lots of people thinking about the
gym of course is a new year's resolution
that when the pandemic began nearly two
years ago indoor gyms were one of the
first businesses to be completely shut
down now the industry is hoping the new
year will draw many customers back and
joining me now is the managing director
for try yoga gyms jonathan satin a very
happy new year to you jonathan thanks
for being with us is it going to be a
happy new year though for your industry
do you think you took such a hit didn't
you during lockdown did lots of those
customers come back
i think good morning happy new year to
youtube and i think uh it's been a slow
process
from uh really for us from september of
last year it started to really rebuild
um and then sadly when uh so the plan b
has kicked in it has slowed the numbers
down again
yeah so uh new year is a time of course
when many of us think about uh getting
fit again um uh
what are you seeing in terms of people
signing up and wanting to get back
i think it's a genuine intention for
people to come back i think people need
to feel um feel safe
and and be safe so we've been very
careful throughout the pandemic to
to do that with a whole raft of
protocols and during plan b we also are
recommended for people to
uh do a lateral flow test before they
come in but i think a lot of it depends
on what the government guidelines are
going to be over the next month or so
another issue of course is uh sickness
amongst staff how's that
impacting things
yes interesting so uh in the last month
or so we've noticed that we've had a
much higher
sickness rate either through people
being ill or or self-isolating so pre-uh
christmas we had um in one of our
centers 30 to 40 percent of the front of
house team were were away
something else that was quite
interesting uh during the pandemic was
this huge surge in people exercising at
home whether it was through sort of live
streaming classes also those stationary
bikes i won't mention the name but you
know what i'm talking about that have
really taken off
is that damaging the business
uh no we we we're a yoga pilates and
treatment center so um what we did in
the very first pandemic very first sort
of lockdown we we went online so we were
running around over 100 classes a week
online
and running workshops online and so on
to enable people to keep their practice
going during lockdown and once we've
reopened we now run a sort of hybrid
classes where you can both come to the
center and also take that that class
online so when people don't feel
comfortable to come back in or sometimes
it's more convenient
the ability to practice both from home
and in center is great
yeah good idea and finally as we head
into 2022 now what are your your hopes
uh for this year
so i hope that well i hope firstly that
we all get healthy and i think um one
way for people to do that is to come
back into into yoga centers and gyms
and uh my hope would be the government
support us um in helping the nation get
healthy and there are a number of ways
they could be doing that
i'll tell you what i would like um gyms
to be a bit cheaper they seem so
expensive you've got any good offers on
we always have good offers on
and actually one thing talking about
that if the government for example would
make a health and well-being vat exempt
it would be a good way to reduce pricing
as well
okay yeah good point all right jonathan
great to speak to you jonathan satin
from trioger james thank you very much
indeed thank you
okay let's see how the rest of the
weekend is shaping up weather-wise
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
we'll keep the warm southwesterly today
but it will turn colder next week as the
winds become more northerly it's mostly
mild but windy now with a scattering of
showers over central and western parts
but southern britain and eastern parts
of both scotland and ireland are mostly
fine the morning will stay windy with
blustery showers taking over more of the
west frequent and prolonged in places
eastern britain will largely dry up it's
going to be colder than yesterday still
very mild however for january
so time to look at sunday's papers then
with international business expert
alison stewart allen and sunday mary's
political editor nigel nelson great to
see you both again uh nigel let's kick
off shall we with the front of the
sunday times uh the nhs uh struggling
they're saying that one in ten staff are
out because of uh sickness and covid
causing all sorts of issues
yes i mean the the the they said there
were 110 000
nhs staff over new year
and 50 000 of those were either
sick with covered or isolating because
of it
so this is kind of the other major
consideration that boris johnson has got
to take into account
uh when deciding this week whether more
restrictions need to come in
it's not just hospitalizations which
matter or the number of hospitalizations
it's obviously a question of is there an
are there enough staff to look after
them
um and those are the various things
coming in and what the the nhs warns is
that they still may not be able to cope
now obviously what boris johnson will
try and do this week is to stave off um
any more rules and regulations uh
uh to stop us
going out um but obviously that puts him
out of sync with what is going on with
the rest of the uk northern ireland
scotland and wales
yeah interestingly uh the mail on sunday
says just one in 40 hospital staff are
off due to covid they're interpreting
the data slightly differently but nigel
whichever way you look at it um
you know people are off for a maximum of
of of seven days at the minimum seven
days at the moment so it's going to have
that knock-on effect
yes i mean this is the problem and the
last official figures
um were actually showing that um a
thousand nhs staff a day were going were
going down with covid or isolating so
whichever way you cut it there's an
awful lot a lot of adopters and nurses
who are not around at the moment and
obviously the question is whether that
gets worse yeah we shall wait and see
it's a sort of watch and wait situation
isn't it at the moment let's talk about
something completely different um alison
this is in the sun
a warning of metal being found in packs
of
butter tell me about this
yes well it's quite worrying
clearly
people who might be putting you know
buttering their toast as we are live now
uh and think gee what is this in our
butter
uh clearly in the manufacturing process
something has gone profoundly wrong
uh and any brand that has
quality control uh issues like this
should be very worried and hopefully
this spurs a number of companies that
especially make food products uh to make
sure that in the course of the
manufacturing process uh something
doesn't go awry uh but it isn't uh a
completely new phenomenon you know there
have been product recalls uh for uh you
know manufacturing issues in the past
you know of course uh they aren't as
great as this most of the time uh but
nonetheless it's a very expensive
undertaking but the most important
aspect to all this
is that it makes us not trust the brand
uh and if you think about all of the
money uh that this butter company is
spending uh to get us to buy that
product uh and then suddenly we have
doubts about its health you know health
and safety uh issues around this brand
uh that's a very expensive undertaking
to restore our trust uh and that's gonna
mean a lot of money uh but importantly
for the company it's gonna mean
re-checking uh and reassuring the
customers but rechecking the
manufacturing process
now it's uh it's quite a worrying thing
for any food product uh to have to do a
recall yeah especially we have such good
standards don't we here in the uk that's
and helen's farm goats butter 250 gram
packs have been recalled with uh a an
expiration date up to march 13th 2022.
let's talk about politics uh nigel uh i
think it's fair to say the the year
didn't end particularly well for uh the
prime minister on uh on many fronts and
the polls are reflecting that
yes that's right the year is not
beginning very well for the prime
minister either um this is a poll in the
men on sunday uh and they've had a look
at the 57 seat that boris johnson won in
2019.
these are the red wall seats that he he
took from labor
and what it's showing is it gives labor
a 16 point lead which is uh phenomenal i
mean we were closing the year on about
eight points ahead um but
this would mean if there was a general
election tomorrow the victories would
lose a hundred seats
however um kierstama shouldn't celebrate
too much yet
uh because that would still only deliver
a hung parliament so you can see the
electoral mountain that uh labor has to
climb and obviously we are actually at
least two years off from a general
election
and an awful lot can happen in the in
that intervening time yeah of course uh
it really can um alison something else
uh uh to talk about uh when it comes to
um retail um and something my wife and i
have talked about actually uh in the
last few days that uh the way we return
things that we buy online has really
improved massively over the last uh
couple of years really it's now much
much easier than it used to be
it certainly is but you know from the
retailer's perspective
uh the latest uh study uh and analysis
suggests that it's costing
uk retailers seven billion pounds uh to
process our returns now you could say
well that's just a cost of business they
have to they should be doing that uh to
keep our custom to keep us loyal uh but
uh you know if you think about the fact
that one in three
uh garments are returned uh and several
other household items and things that we
send back especially in in the garment
and fashion sector you know there's this
phenomenon of uh people one in ten
supposedly who make a purchase of a
garment take a picture of themselves in
it uh and send it back uh and the sole
purpose of the order was just to take a
photo of them wearing this item
yeah
well from the retailers point of view
you know uh this is expensive because
you have to steam the item you have to
clean it you have to put it back up for
resale in a warehouse so all the postage
costs and the logistics surrounding
returns
get quite expensive which is why in many
cases amazon for example will just say
forget it keep the item and we'll just
give you a gift card or we'll we'll add
this to your gift account which then
makes sure that we come back and buy
from amazon again so a lot of online
retailers are just often saying it's too
much hassle it's too much money
keep the item and we'll just give you
that back in a refund in the form of a
credit on your account yeah interesting
but yes it's expensive business yeah and
of course the other thing people do as
well is is perhaps buy two or three uh
the same item but in different sizes so
that when they get it home they can try
them all on find out which one works and
then send the others back and it's not
particularly good for the environment
either is it when you think of all those
delivery vans and all the rest of it um
let's turn to the sunday times business
section nigel tell me about this bbc
boss backs youtube 500 million dollar
youtube buying spree
oh i think that that's probably alison's
isn't it was that one for alison okay
well you want to talk to me about alien
lizards then nigel
well why not i mean
that's from sublime to the ridiculous
isn't it um yeah this is the front page
of the of the star which always like
some uh an off-the-wall splash
and it's a survey which shows that 12
percent of uh millennials aged between
24 and 35
actually believe the david i conspiracy
theory
um that world leaders are actually uh
reptilian humanoids
now the star even has a an editorial on
this they conclude this can't possibly
be true uh because if boris johnson was
a lizard he wouldn't be able to keep
quiet about it
i suppose there is a wider issue here
though isn't there nigel of conspiracy
theories and uh stuff that goes round
and round on on the internet and we know
about sort of the the the anti-vaxx
campaigns as as well and uh there is a
serious side to this
yeah there is i mean i i mean i tend not
to believe conspiracy theories i think
that governments are perfectly capable
of just cocking things up rather than
actually there's a conspiracy behind it
um but obviously the serious side is
that the anti-vaxx conspiracy theories
really are serious if it prevents people
getting jabbed yeah okay all right well
we'll we'll ask you about the bbc on
youtube but in the next hour alison but
for now alison nigel thank you both very
much indeed